voilà plus je trouve ça scandaleux
depuis le début de l'été que je suis
arrivé sur le plateau on ne parle que du
fait qu'il faille battre le front
national systématiquement entendu à
toutes les sauces une fois qu'on quand
on est contre la droite quand on est
contre la gauche
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
français ont fait des choix et il me
semble que la première des choses ça
serait de les respecter
voilà c'est tout c'est tout ce que ça me
ça m'inspire comme réaction non
l'élection n'est pas fini mais on peut
au moins respecter le choix des français
quand ils portent des candidats qui font
plus de 40 % dans certains cantons nous
semble que c'est quand même la moindre
des choses c'est de respecter leur choix
et il faut les candidats du front
national ont été élus sur un programme
qui est défini qui éclaire qui est
précis au réseau nac on a très peu
entendu dans les débats sur la direction
départementale mais vous l'avez j'étais
genre et discuter ici après vous pouvez
inviter d'autres candidats et vous aurez
certainement dit oui françois xavier
dugourd on vient d'entendre françois
rebsamen dire qu'il appellerait à voter
pour le candidat de la droite
républicaine il attend juste retour que
sam a eu des positions et pierre
premièrement ras-le-bol de cette
politique où on se dit propriétaire des
voix des électeurs
pire les électeurs ils sont grands ils
vont décider en responsabilité par
rapport aux propositions qui seront
faites par les candidats
par ailleurs moi je rappelle que je ne
partage d'idées les valeurs du front
national ni celle du parti socialiste
je rappelle que le parti socialiste ne
souhaite pas lutter contre la fraude
sociale il a refusé le débat une au
conseil général
il souhaite y augmenter le prix des
cantines scolaires mais je parle du
conseil général parce que je crois que
aujourd'hui c'est un débat sur les
élections départementales donc le parti
socialiste souhaite augmenter le prix
des tarifs
le tarif détaillé des cantines scolaires
c'est très clair puisque peu fixé c'est
dans le programme le prix des cantines
en fonction des revenus
le parti socialiste souhaite limiter la
libre de la liberté d'enseignement ils
souhaitent arrêter stopper la politique
de soutien à l'enseignement privé comme
à l'enseignement public
donc voilà c'est sûr ça c'est sur ces
propositions que nous nous battrons et
par rapport au front national on l'a
observé effectivement les professions de
foi effectivement il ya relativement peu
de propositions sur le département
nini si je comprends bien très
clairement il ya un truc